Les vieux et la technologie, c'est.... Enfin, c'est pas encore... Enfin c'est particulier quoi.
Déjà quand ils en parlent...quand ils parlent de la technologie...
J'ai l'impression qu'ils font TOUT leur possible, ils font leur maximum... pour se tromper !
Oulala ! Je capte mal la Wii-fit !
Je vais peut être redémarrer la Pasta-Box.
Pasta-Box...
D'ailleurs, un des passe temps des vieux : mettre un article là où y en a pas.
Par exemple :
Vas-y montre moi ton truc sur l'Internet.
"Internet". Pas "L'internet". Répétez après moi : "Internet".
Ah mais tu sais que moi aussi je vais sur le Facebook.
Juste "Facebook", c'est plus net.
Mes parents, par exemple, ils galèrent mais ils galèrent à un niveau professionnel quoi !
C'est... Ils essayent mais ils font n'importe quoi !
Ma mère, quand elle fait une recherche sur Internet, elle fait ça :
Alors...
Goo...gle...point...com
Voilà
Là, au moins, t'es sûr d'être sur Google. Là c'est certain, il n'y a pas de doute, tu t'es pas trompé de site.
Et je crois que ma mère c'est la personne qui tape le moins vite au monde sur un clavier.
Ça je m'en suis spécialement rendu compte quand elle m'a ajouté sur Facebook.
*musique angoissante*
What?!
Oui, parce qu'elle pense que "LOL" ça veut dire "Oui" sur Internet.
Enfin bon bref, c'est irrécupérable, on ne peut plus rien pour elle.
le truc que je déteste le plus,
c'est quand mes parents m'appellent pour que je les aide en informatique.
ils sont tellement mauvais, que vraiment, je me demande ce qu'ils comprennent
"J'ai un document sur ma clé USB,
je veux le mettre sur l'ordi, comment je fais ?"
- "D'accord, d'abord tu ouvres la fenêtre".
- "Ouais, j’ouvre la fenêtre..."
- "tu copies le document "
- " je copie le document."
- "et ensuite tu le colles..."
- " je le colle..."
- "...sur le bureau."
- "et voilà. Merci Cyprien. "
- "LOL!"
- "Ah ta mère te dit LOL."
D'ailleurs j'ai un petit message, à toutes les personnes âgées qui regardent cette vidéo
Arrêtez... tout de suite... de manière immédiate le jeu de mot...
Face de bouc. On arrête... s'il vous plait.
Vous n'avez jamais remarqué qu'à chaque fois que vous faites ce jeu de mot,
les jeunes rigolent de cette manière?
Alors, on va sur Face de Bouc ?
Alors, parfois ils pensent avoir découvert des trucs par eux-mêmes, hein.
Il y a quelques jours mon père pensait avoir découvert Ruzzle.
Avoir fait une découverte...
Alors moi du coup, je lui ai dit: Ah, c'est un bon jeu, c'est sympa.
Sachant que ça fait un an que tous les jeunes n'y jouent déjà plus.
Comme si les vieux attendaient un an ou deux avant de pratiquer la technologie.
Ruzzle? Oulala, laisse moi un an ou deux et peut être je vais y jouer, mais je suis pas sûr.
Après les plus à plaindre ça reste les grands-parents, hein.
Moi, mon grand-père ça fait deux ans qu'il a un téléphone portable.
A chaque fois qu'il sonne, on a l'impression qu'il redécouvre l'objet.
Quelle est cette chose?
Qu'est ce que... qu'est ce que c'est?
Sans oublier qu'à chaque fois qu'il sort, il laisse son téléphone portable à la maison.
Faudrait que je lui explique, euh, peut être, le mot, "portable", dans téléphone portable.
Ça veut dire que tu peux le porter, c'est... waou!
Enfin bref, pour résumer, je pense que les vieux voient les jeunes de cette manière...
Tu peux m'enlever le mode avion, s'il te plait?
Oui pas de problème.
C'est très très simple.
Voilà.
Merci.
Allez, à bientôt.
Téléportation!
Ah oui, avant de se quitter, partagez cette vidéo.